- But I have to ask you this
'cause Joe Biden is now President
and I heard him say,
- What?
- I know it's exciting,
but I heard--
- I thought
it was still out,
I thought there was no conceding.
- No, no, no.
- I didn't think,
so he won.
- He is President,
I was there in the office with him.
- Okay, great.
- Yes.
- Oh, that's right!
- And I was, and he did say
that Will and Grace did
more than anything else
to shift like how people
viewed gay marriage.
- Yeah.
- And I never really thought about that,
but I think that's absolutely true.
- Isn't that amazing?
- Especially reaching
on a broad scale, like so many.
you're in the homes of, you know,
- Yeah.
- all across America.
- I, I mean, look,
I got the, when I got the pilot,
which is the first episode,
- Yeah.
- I was 27 years old.
- So just
a couple of years ago, but I,
(laughing)
thanks, that took just a second.
- Me too,
me too.
- But, no
and I was just happy to
get a job on a TV show.
I had no idea that the by-product
would be something that
was bigger than all of us
and then I'm sitting at
home on the couch one day,
I remember this is when Joe
Biden was the Vice President
and he said something on
MSNBC or I don't know, some show
and he was like, Will and Grace
did more to educate America
about the gay movement than anything
and I was like, what?
Like I was just crazy.
- I think it's true though,
art does inspire like real life.
Like I think, real life inspires art
I guess chicken and egg.
- Yeah.
- But, but yeah, I, I
think it's absolutely true,
I just never thought about it
until you said it.
- Also,
it's the power of comedy.
It's the power of, of comedy is, is
the ability to educate people
without them knowing it
because if they're enjoying you,
there's no, you can't,
- Yeah.
- you can't combat that,
right, right?
- Yeah, I agree.